30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become
get fill on the app store or Google Play
hi everyone it's Joanna here I'm super
excited to be doing another workout
series with our field trainers and today
I have the lovely Marissa here with me
hi everybody Marissa is a Fitness and
Nutrition coach and she has been in the
industry for over a decade so Marissa
what will we be doing today so we're
going to be working our legs bums and
Tums what you need today is one medium
dumbbell one light dumbbell and a step
we're going to really get ready and work
into those muscles that we love so much
let's do this
foreign
[Music]
Joanna let's do this all right we're
going to go into a deep squat
have your legs nice and wide have your
elbows inside the knees tuck your
fingers under your toes and we're going
to lift the hips up
and drop back down
let's do this a few times
I'm just opening up the hips warming up
the hips feeling that nice stretch the
back of your legs
do a couple more here
[Applause]
and one more
and let's come all the way up all right
we're going to do a lunge with a Twist
over the front leg let's start off with
that right leg here we go stepping
forward twist over back and to the other
side
[Music]
also focus on your breathing don't hold
that breath
let's do one more each side
feeling a little bit warm okay we're
gonna go into some good morning so
you're gonna have your feet hip with the
pot have your hands resting behind your
head you're going to hinge the hips to
the back tuck that belly button in nice
and tight up we come and here we go
nice and strong in your abdomen
two more
last one
okay we're gonna come down into all
fours we're gonna go into a bear crawl
position
okay knees close to the ground we're
gonna walk a little bit forward and back
let's go front first
and back imagine you've got a teacup
full of hot water on your back and you
don't want it to drop
[Music]
let's do this one more time
[Music]
okay staying here let's just drop our
knees down to the floor I'm going to
warm up those glutes a little bit more
we're going to lift up our right leg
into the fire hydrant and back down
really preparing
our glutes and our legs for the upcoming
workout
a couple more here
okay let's switch sides
[Music]
feel that squeeze at the top
a couple more
all right okay let's come on up
okay we're gonna get our step
and your heavy dumbbell
so you can look over to Joanna who's
going to take tight regression on this
movement she's going to bring her leg a
little bit lower and not use a dumbbell
I'm going to go a little bit higher so
with the workout how it goes It's Time
based it's 40 seconds work 20 seconds
recovery and just listen out for the
changes are we ready to do this let's do
this okay we're gonna get our right leg
up onto the step
and in three two one here we go dropping
down
pushing through that left leg
nice and balanced
inhale as you go down exhale as you come
up
nice and tall in the upper body
strong in the core
feeling that and your left leg
and all right I'm going to change over
to the other side
let's get that left leg foot up onto the
step
okay
nice and tight here
in the core shoulders back if you're
holding that weight and down we go
this is a good time to notice
if you're slightly imbalanced on one
side
that's why we do these unilateral
movements
to balance out those imbalances
[Music]
it's 10 seconds here just a few more
reps
foreign
shake the legs out Okay so we've got one
more round
we're gonna switch halfway it's gonna be
20 seconds each leg
and I've got the dumbbell we're going to
do a underpass with this as I come down
I bring the dumbbell Under and Over okay
so we're gonna start
and here we go
all right
you need to use a lighter dumbbell for
this
okay we're gonna go for the switch
the legs
[Music]
almost there
and we got one more in
okay good work all right we can put the
step aside
[Music]
I'm Gonna Keep a dumbbell close by
we're gonna come and lie down onto the
ground we're going to go into a single
leg glute Bridge let's bend the left leg
extend the right leg out and lift
the glutes up and lower okay keep your
foot flexed and think about lifting the
glutes
and the leg will follow
now you can have your hands by your side
or you can even have them crossed over
your chest
so you really use the lower body to lift
feeling that on your left hamstring
oh okay give yourself a hug
how are we going there Joanna feeling my
glutes and my eyes all right let's
switch sides
[Music]
starting in a few seconds take a deep
breath
in three two one here we go lift
really push those hips up
let's just see which muscle
is working more here is it the hamstring
this is the glutes you might even feel
it in your calves
few more reps here
oh okay
let's grab a weight okay we're gonna
place that onto your hips it's gonna be
a weighted glute Bridge
okay so both feet planted onto the
ground and we're gonna lift push up and
coming on down so just having that
little added weight
and here we go
[Music]
get that extra squeeze at the top
squeezing the glutes
uh
it is a legs and bums workout
we're really gonna
put those muscles
to work
all right Joanna let's hold it up
everybody hold it up hold it hold it
hold it squeeze
in three two one and lower down
okay
we're gonna come back standing
what's the leg workout without squats so
with a weight or without a weight we're
going to be doing Tempo two seconds down
two seconds up so we ready and here we
go so one two one two one two one two
now feel
the weight onto your heels as you squat
this way we know we're doing
a good squat so that the pressure is not
on the knees
and you don't want your
upper body to be collapsing forward
one more here
okay we're gonna keep to the squats
we're going to change the tempo we're
going to go for three seconds down hold
for a second and then power up all right
so it's three one one
all right three two one here we go so
three two one hold power up
three
two one hold
power out so you've got it
and you know what to do
squeeze
you want to squeeze those quads those
hamstrings those glutes
your abs
are you holding a weight your shoulders
and arms are working as well
one more here
okay
all right one more round pulses
squats and pulses to really get those
muscles burning so how it's going to
work is we're gonna come down we're
gonna do three pulses three two one and
then up we come 40 seconds okay here we
go
three two one up
it doesn't feel so painful when you've
got a friend working out with you oh I'm
feeling the bird
helps to keep you going
10 more seconds
we got this
one more pulse three two one and up okay
you're gonna grab your light dumbbell
we're gonna come into our all fours
position
we're gonna tuck this behind
your knee
you keep that foot flexed and we're
gonna do a pulse really getting into
those glutes and here we go
now be careful of your positioning here
you want to engage your
core your abdomen here your abs pull
that belly button in so that your belly
is not dropping
and make sure that your
wrists are in line with your shoulders
somehow this exercise really builds up
the heat
10 seconds here
oh my gosh
three two one
ah that's when you know you've got
your boots
all right let's switch sides
you can even feel this you can really
feel this even without a weight that's
right even without the weights
okay let's lift that leg up Flex that
foot if you've got the dumbbell in there
make sure it's secure
pull that belly button into the spine
let's keep on going keep pulsing that
leg
foreign
[Music]
keep on going don't drop that leg
in four
three
two
one and recover
almost lost the dumbbell there okay now
we're gonna work both sides of the
glutes together we're going to come into
our frog leg position so knees wide
heels connected rest your forehead onto
your hands and we're going to lift the
thighs off the floor here we go
one of my favorite
non-weighted
glute exercises
oh I'm really feeling it
also works your lower back a little bit
too because that's gonna get
help you lift
almost there Joanna come on everyone
10 seconds less than 10 seconds
oh
my gosh
we've got one more here we got our rdls
so grab your heavier dumbbell
I'm gonna have the dumbbell in your
right hand
and we're gonna lift that right leg
leading with the heel
and back down all right here we go
find that balance
now it's okay if your body doesn't come
parallel to the floor even just coming
to this position and back up is
perfectly fine
so you should be feeling this in the
hamstring
on your base leg
just remember where your center of
gravity is
it's around here
so don't just rely on the foot and the
ankle to balance you
all right switching sides
oh I get a nice this one feels like a
really nice recovery
[Laughter]
okay
get your feet hip width apart
here we go on the other side
and lift
just letting that weight drop
naturally down in front of you
really working the posterior chain here
back
your glutes your hamstring
one more
all right okay
we're gonna do an alternate
RDL with a knee lift so it's going to
look like this you're going to hold your
dumbbell you're going to bring that
right leg up and bring your knee up then
you're gonna bring that left leg up and
bring the knee up all right are we ready
let's do this here we go
right side drive that knee up your
dumbbell is going to move to bring make
space for that knee to come up to your
chest
lots of balance here
our biceps get to work a little bit as
well as you lift that dumbbell
okay
[Music]
all right we're into our final round
we're going to be working the core the
ABS and it's all to do with the plank so
we've got 10 exercises and I'm going to
do them for 30 seconds each with a 15
second break in between
we're going to start off with the plank
with our arms nice and straight let's
come down onto our mat
we're going to have our wrists in line
with the shoulders
in three two one here we go just hold
that plank
now imagine your feet are pushing
against the wall your legs are activated
push the floor away with your hands
and pull that belly button in towards
your spine
everything is working here to hold this
body into a nice
plank strong plank position
a few more seconds
and just drop down to the knees all
right we're going to go into a side
plank coming down onto your forearm you
can look at Joanna for a bit of a
regression here
I'm gonna stack my feet up
and I'm going to have my arm up in the
air and hold
foreign
so make sure you're pushing your hips up
towards the ceiling have space between
your ear and your shoulder
look straight ahead and breathe
you feel a little bit of a shake
that's your deep core muscles working
hard
and gently come on down all right let's
switch to the other side
and in three two one up we go
foreign
ERS get those hips higher push them up
really working our oblique muscles
the ones closest to the mat
I know you might feel this a bit on your
shoulder just hold it hold it
15 second break any second
okay we're gonna go into a forearm plank
to dolphin
quite like this it's a bit of a recovery
I'm gonna really open up the chest and
stretch out the shoulders so come into
that plank position then you're going to
push your hips up towards the sky your
chest towards your thighs and back into
that forearm Plank and push
just really enjoy that stretch
when you're in that dolphin position
get one more in
awesome okay we're gonna go do a plank
rotation again just to look at Joanna
for a bit of a regression here so we're
going to be in our forearm plank we're
going to scoop the arm under and then
we're gonna swivel to the side of our
feet and come into that side plank back
onto the tippy toes and open into that
side leg
make sure you get that switch
from the toes the side of the feet
a few more seconds here
last one
okay let's bring those Knees Down have a
little bit of right arms might be
feeling it
I'm going to switch on to the other side
we okay that Joanna yes feeding the core
all right let's come back up and other
side
[Music]
so Joanna got a really nice regression
there still working
on that rotation
[Music]
a couple more
one more
oh Saved by the Bell
okay we're gonna come into a
full arm Plank and Toes Taps so push
your hips up tap the toe back into that
plank and tap the opposite side
[Music]
you might be getting a little bit tired
but
keep it up we're almost there pull that
belly button in nice and tight
[Music]
30 seconds goes by pretty quickly all
right we're gonna do spider
cool maybe just give your shoulders a
little bit of a roll
coming back into that plank position
we're going to bring our knee
to our elbow and switching sides here we
go
we've got two more after this one
[Music]
really try to connect the knee and the
elbow
[Music]
oh have a little bit of a stretch back
we're gonna get ready for our up down
planks or Commando planks
they have our full arms extended and we
come down onto the forearms
and back up 30 seconds
[Music]
Midway we're gonna change
with a slide that we're leading
just to even it out
all right change with the side
[Music]
so we don't become too dominant on one
side
all right
[Music]
all right
hip dips one final workout
final 30 seconds we're coming down into
our forearms and we're gonna swivel our
hips to the sides making beautiful
rainbows to finish this workout
[Music]
the ABS have gotten a good workout
all right and this last block
eight seconds
[Music]
almost there
and gently drop your knees down
that was good okay I'm gonna give Joanna
a nice high five high five thank you now
we're gonna stretch it out it's just
coming to a nice child's pose open up
those knees
push your bum back to your heels have
your arms stretched out and just relax
for a few moments here
uh
[Music]
[Music]
okay just gently coming up it's coming
up into all fours
we're going to scoop our arm through
thread our arms through and coming back
down keep those hips up
you can stretch out your other arm
shoulders got a lot of work too from the
plank
and all the plank variations
and coming back up
let's go over to the other side thread
that arm through
and stretch out that arm
[Music]
and coming back up come back up onto all
fours I'm going to lie down on our front
let's grab your foot and bring your
heels to your bum give the quad's a good
stretch
and switching to the other side
release let's come up to a fitted
position
let's bring our legs out in front of us
that's gonna have our feet nice and flex
and we can feel that stretch at the back
of the leg so let's take a nice deep
inhale bring your arms overhead exhale
folding forward
just reaching where you can as long as
you're feeling that nice stretch down
the back of the legs
we did a lot a lot of work
and the hamstrings and the glutes
let's bring our legs in let's connect
the feet
connect your elbows and your knees as
you drop your chest down to your feet
press leg down
feel quite nice in the hips feel very
warm
[Music]
and relief has just come into a nice
comfortable
seated position let's just interlock our
fingers around the upper back
let's bring our palms up towards the
ceiling stretch
[Music]
and release let's take one nice deep
breath to finish today's workout inhale
as you exhale bring your hands to Heart
Center
[Music]
thank you so much Marissa I really had a
good workout and I'm I'm really feeling
it in my legs as well as my core so if
you enjoyed this workout be sure to let
us know in the comments below and don't
forget to check out a lot more workouts
by Marissa on the fuel app download for
free on the App Store or Google play or
go onto our website fieldlife.com and
get special discounts thank you once
again Marissa if you haven't yet
subscribed to my YouTube channel then go
ahead and hit the Subscribe button don't
forget to follow Marissa on her IG and
let us know how you felt in today's
workout in the comments below and we'll
see you next time thank you bye